finding this is comforting people young
actors out there should take solace
because although the success was very
fast everything not all the auditions
went that really the beginning do you
know the one I'm talking about the one
with Dino De Laurentiis Oh
auditioning yes yes yes well that was
for King Kong no yes yes the girl she's
very good yeah that was Dino De
Laurentiis senior and his son had seen
me in a play and so I went up to the top
of the gulf and western building that
like the 33rd floor and he had this
amazing office that looked all over
Manhattan and he was back there and I
walked in and and his son was sitting
there very excited that he brought in
this new actress and the father said to
his son in Italian because I understand
tiny said gay brother you know why do
you bring me this ugly thing very
sobering so I said to him me this Piazza
Motoman you know but I understand what
you're saying I'm sorry I'm not
beautiful enough to be in Kings table
[Applause]
[Music]
so I started to cry and I said and
they'll probably if they ever hear that
stuff sank Wow would really keep him
he's an absolute bastard
oh the sword of the Lord Of Shadows
blood here we go
[Music]
[Applause]